The bell's been wrung
out in the dark
among thestars
the god is dead
I had a dream
almost like a premonition i
think there's an attack coming
My lord
this wall will fall
I need warriors i'm building
an alliance to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull then don't wave the red cape at it
you were sent here for a reason and even
if it takes you the rest of your life
find out what that reason is
they said the age of heroes would never come again
it will it has to
we live in a society where
honor is a distant memory isn't that right
batman
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my justice league snyder cut trailer video
we live in a society where they drop trailers a
couple hours early to prevent people from leaking
the entire thing there's a whole bunch of new
footage a ton of easter eggs and we officially
got our new look at jared leto's joker in
the snyder cut so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'll be doing
videos for this in the next month and when it
comes out because it's going to be over 4 hours
long so it'll be a lot of fun to see what other
new stuff is in here i'm also assuming that the
soundtrack that they put on the trailer is part
of the soundtrack of the official movie but it
starts with a much longer version of that scene
of superman screaming during batman v superman
when he's in the process of dying and you get that
lex luthor voice over that we actually got in the
teaser trailer way back last year a long time ago
talking about how god is dead the bell's been rung
the cry has been heard only this time the way they
cut the trailer the extra detail they've added is
that you see superman's cries are creating sound
waves that are so powerful that the way they cut
it they make it sound like they hear it all the
way on themschira although i don't know that
that's the case though because when you see that
big temple falling into the ocean i think that's
actually from the steppenwolf attack and not from
superman's cries when he's dying during batman v
superman it's just the way they cut the trailer
that makes it seem like it's happening that way
i believe the actual steppenwolf attack still
happens during the same time period as it did
during the theatrical cut still pretty early in
the movie when steppenwolf arrives to start going
around stealing all the mother boxes to combine
them so they can start taking over the earth
again but i believe the person that's standing on
the cliff face here is supposed to be hippolyta
there's some of that same batman voiceover that
we got at all the original theatrical cut trailers
where he talks about i have a dream and then it's
basically the same conversation when he talks
about the attack he's talking about the events
of the nightmare scene that he saw during batman
v superman but he's telling the other members of
the justice league in alfred and i'm not sure if
a lot of this nightmare footage was originally
shot when they were shooting batman v superman
or if it's all additional stuff that they did
while they were filming justice league because
originally i believe that this was all supposed
to happen a little bit later in the timeline but
then when they told zack snyder that he wasn't
going to get multiple justice league films
i think a long time ago he changed some of his
plans and then started adding the nightmare stuff
to batman v superman i think along the years there
were like 10 or 15 different versions of what his
five movie plan was going to be inside dc films
but this time when they go across the landscape
you see more parademons flying around you see
dark sized ships just strip mining earth of all
of its resources that's basically what he does
going around conquering planets in the universe
he uses other planets from the universe to provide
resources for apocalypse to fuel his engines of
war more and more then they go to the greek temple
where wonder woman is investigating the site where
hippalta shot the arrow from justice league there
was a version that in theatrical cup where she
basically fires the warning arrow but i believe
thousands of years ago during the events of that
dark side war flashback wonder woman had not been
born yet or if she had she was just like a tiny
little baby because all the greek gods are still
alive so they haven't had their civil war yet
where aries goes around killing the rest of them
we got a version of this scene last year when zack
snyder started dropping all those teasers but as
you can see it just tells the story of that dark
side war where you have all the tribes of man you
have the atlanteans you have the amazonians all
coming together with some of the green lanterns to
defeat uxes before he had taken the name darkseid
and taken the omega force like you see him with
the omega symbol upside down the indentation on
his chest but then we do actually get some scenes
of him in his actual costume i'm not totally sure
if this is actually happening on apocalypse or
if this is happening during the nightmare scene
and it's from the future alternate timeline where
he's taken over the earth but the character on the
left is assad we've seen him in previous trailers
the character on the right the female character
obviously is granny goodness maybe we'll see some
of the furious during the movie in the background
we get a very different version of the scene
where steppenwolf starts putting all the mother
boxes together it looks like he summons a visage
of darkseid and starts communicating with him
there was a very different explainer for what was
going on with the mother boxes when the theatrical
cut came out i don't know if that's going to be
the same for the mother boxes in the snyder cut
so we'll just wait and see because we don't
see steppenwolf in the trailer referring to
the mother boxes themselves as mother the whole
explainer for the theatrical cut is the reason
why he kept calling the mother box's mother is
because they contain the soul of his mother who
was supposed to be hegra which is a little bit
weird because hegra is actually darkseid's mother
and steppenwolf is supposed to be his uncle but
the reason why he called the three mother boxes
the unity is because he was going to unify her
soul and use her power to take over the earth
but the way zack snyder explains it in the snyder
cup we see more of the actual anti-life equation
from the comics so they didn't really get into
the anti-life equation during the theatrical cut
in the whole relationship between steppenwolf
and darkseid during the snyder cut is that
steppenwolf is basically trying to get back in
darkseid's good graces so that he can come back
to apocalypse because up to this point for a while
he's been living in exile because of some failures
that he suffered a long time ago this is just the
altered version of that scene of him attacking all
the amazonians stealing their mother box there's a
slightly different version of that scene of batman
going to recruit aquaman then we get a slightly
different version of the scene of wonder woman
saving all those people in london from that
bomb and i believe there's supposed to be a
ton more aquaman stuff going on because volkow
was originally in the cut before they took him
out now he's obviously back in because the snyder
cut includes all the stuff that he wanted to put
in the movie i believe a lot of these extra
scenes during this part of the story line are
just to give more context to his relationship with
atlantis when he goes back to get his armor in his
mother's trident it's a little hard to tell but
i believe this new scene of cyborg is from the
nightmare scene because he's actually one of the
people that helped send flash back in time there's
this whole time travel plot that they were going
to get into during the justice league sequels
where they send the flash back in time to warn
batman to save lois lane so that they can stop
superman from falling to dark side in the
anti-life equation the way zack snyder explained
it too back during dc fandom last year is that
we would see some quote-unquote new abilities
from the flash in the way he talked about it imply
we would actually see him time travel during the
movie and that was sort of helped set up the idea
of what's going on with flashpoint him traveling
the multiverse just a lot of extra abilities that
we'll see during the flash movie as well these are
just more scenes from the final battle with them
all attacking steppenwolf space i believe this
part of the movie is also supposed to be very very
different in the way that it goes down we get the
brand new line of dialogue from alfred talking
about waving the red cape so to speak superman's
red cape at the bowl who is steppenwolf although
you could also think of dark side as well really
dark side is the threat from the nightmare scene
that batman is thinking about but steppenwolf is
the more obvious more immediate threat during the
movie this is the new version of the resurrection
scene and the krotonian ship i believe this is
also supposed to go down in a very different way
than it did during the theatrical cut as well i
believe this scene of cyborg when he's whole again
is visualizing this scene like the scene with
all the missiles from the previous trailers that
we've seen so he's actually cyborg at this point
but he's just using his abilities to visualize
this scene all these scenes of the flash saving
iris west some of you probably seen either in the
leaked scenes from when the theatrical cut came
out because it was a whole bunch of deleted stuff
that just leaked out right after the movie hit
theaters there were also some bits from this in
the earlier teaser trailers from last year as well
i'm not totally sure if they're going to recast
iris west or if they're using this same actress
when the flash movie comes out but they're going
to be filming that pretty soon they've confirmed
that ben affleck's batman is going to show up and
give flash his new time travel his new multiverse
suit as well as michael keaton's batman obviously
showing up they've been hyping him up for the last
six months or so remember the whole way they're
explaining that is that ben affleck's batman is
still going to be the batman of this earth of
justice league earth michael keaton's batman will
come from what we're thinking of is the burton vs
earth there's a very man of steel looking scene
of superman taking off the kryptonian ship wearing
the black suit after he's come back i believe this
was originally footage that zack snyder himself
shot for the justice league that he was going
to release before he left the project so even
though it looks just like it's from man of steel
it was new scenes that he shot for justice league
more scenes of steppenwolf attacking batman's
tank we also get a bunch more scenes of the
actual tank itself it looks like it's right out of
the dark knight returns classic frank miller story
inspired a lot of batman v superman as well this
is another scene of cyborg activating the mother
box and getting a vision of darkseid this scene of
the black suit superman looks like he's going all
ham on steppenwolf during that big final battle
i just i love the way superman looks during this
notice how much better his face looks than it did
during the theatrical cut no weird mustache face
zack snyder made a big deal about that last year
when they announced the snyder cut was going to
be a thing there will be no moments during this
movie where my superman my henry cavill has a
mustache most of you probably know the saga of the
mustache it was all because of the ratios they did
for justice league when joss whedon came on and
the people at paramount wouldn't let him shave
his mustache because he was still in the middle of
filming mission impossible when that was happening
mustache impossible so let's all give a big round
of applause to the fact that they've gotten rid of
any trace of mustache during this movie the way
henry cavill explains it though is that all the
footage of him as superman in the snyder cut was
filmed way back when zack snyder was first working
on the movie he did not participate in any of
the additional photography that they did last
year like the stuff where they shot the new joker
scenes so all this was originally supposed to be
superman's arc during the movie it's not brand
new stuff that he created when he was doing the
snyder cut then i love that tag scene with the
joker talking to batman during the nightmare
scene so obviously that is happening during that
post-apocalyptic future and it's a much older
version of the joker way more city miles on both
of them zack snyder said that their relationship
would be so much more different in the way they
talk it makes it sound like they put their history
behind them and they're now focused on dark side
like they're actually working together to take
down dark side batman and the joker team up that
just kind of blows my mind although i'm assuming
that they're probably not best friends or anything
like that just temporary allies because there's a
bigger threat but it is weird to hear the joker
talking about honor it'll be interesting to see
what the other longer versions of the scenes are
during the actual movie but notably a lot of you
are wondering why there's no martian manhunter
in here i believe the way they accomplish martian
manhunter is through motion capture but there
is martian manhunter in the actual snyder cut as
they say the whole movie is going to be dropping
march 18th is going to be over four hours long
so i'll try to figure out how i'm going to do my
videos for that because it's going to be one long
easter egg breakdown video i might have to break
it into two videos but also a big reminder that's
basically the thursday before falcon and winter
soldier releases so we're going to get the snyder
cut on that thursday i don't know if they're going
to release it at midnight the night before or if
it's going to be at nine in the morning like they
did with wonder woman 1984 then the day after that
the falcon and winter soldier episode 1 releases
so it is going to be crazy in the next month or so
and after the snyder cut releases we'll probably
see them start to drop teasers and trailers for
the suicide squad movie james gunn's been hyping
it up like just you wait we're going to start
releasing trailers eventually but everyone just
post all your reactions in the comments below
and if there are any easter eggs you spotted
in the trailer that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments zack
snyder's always really good about dropping extra
scenes and footage and teasers so there'll
be more of that more footage for the movie
before it actually comes out so of course i'll do
videos for any new stuff that he releases everyone
click here for all those other dc fandom trailers
like the batman trailer the other justice league
snyder cut trailer with the different footage and
click here for my brand new Wandavision episode 7
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and happy valentine's day!